[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition and
for this episode it's going to be all
about the olympics
and the science that undergirds all
sports that unfold
in that great two weeks uh human
competition
and i i got a friend and colleague and
co-author
to help me out here because he thinks
deeply about everything
and that's of course star talks friend
charles luke charles
how you doing man hi neil good great to
see you it's real pleasure good to get
you back uh
thank you so much a level of insight and
knowledge and expertise that transcends
anything any of us have ever brought to
the table and that's why
you've earned i think without question
the title
geek expertise right i think gary were
you the one who first told us that
geek um no but i i do like the
dubbing him the geek in chief the geek
in chief
with geeks let's talk about throwing
stuff
all right so uh where the olympics they
go back
you know gary correct me from wrong 17
no 17. no i'm speaking of american
independence years ago
we are 776
b.c not 1776 bc
76 bc in greece i presume
and this is this is a
a quite the tradition that we've turned
into in modern times
i mean it's extremely it is the obvious
test we've all growing up
who's fastest who can throw something
the furthest who can run up that
mountain and come back down
quickest who can jump over this stream
the furthest so it's it's just basically
the answering of all these questions on
a on a four yearly basis
i think it's a beautiful thing and it's
one of the greatest collaborations of
nations
outside of the waging of war so
well we have to remember that the
olympic games were actually interrupted
for more than 1500 years
it wasn't until 1896 when the modern
olympics began
again after it ended in the roman empire
because indeed the romans didn't want
the olympics to keep going
why not sure why i'm not really sure why
something about nationalism
and and worship of the wrong gods we
lost
maybe that's what it was how could this
happen we're the roman empire
we lost that's it no more olympics
that's so much for a sportsmanship all
right so let's get into the
science of throwing stuff let's start
off with the discus
charles what can you tell me about the
aerodynamics of a discus
why aren't they just sort of throwing a
rock all right what is really cool
is that a disc is way
way more aerodynamic than a sphere in
fact it's way more aerodynamic than an
airplane
it's an amazingly aerodynamic objects so
if you want to see something
fly in the air for a long distance what
you want to do is to throw a disc
and that's the most dramatic thing that
you can do back in those days right you
want to see things go a long way
throwing a brock is fun you know that's
what a shotput is you're basically
pushing this big cannonball but that
don't doesn't go that far
right the discus though can say we all
know that
well maybe most of us know that you can
spin stabilize an object as it moves
through the air
so a spinning football um a
and spinning can also if it's a round
object give it some
uh there'll be a force added on it that
would curve its path
but for for a discus is it better if i
spin it faster like why did what if it's
spinning at all isn't that good enough
why don't what's the with the spinning
faster well
it's really that the faster you start
the spin
the longer it'll stay spinning right
think about
air resistance it'll slow the spinning
down as you go forward
okay so the faster you start the spin
the longer it'll stay spinning the
better it will be as an aerodynamic
object
and thus the more likely it will travel
a farther distance yeah but
but airplane wings are aerodynamic and
they're not spinning
so why must a discus spin at all
it doesn't have to spin if you just sort
of pushed it it would go
you'd end up you would end up at your
toes
you're getting it for the same reason
you get the spinning for the same reason
that when you throw a frisbee
right or a spinning disc or a flying
disc or whatever it is
right if you get more spin it'll stay up
longer that
it stabilizes the flight doesn't it yeah
and therefore if it's more stable
it travels further yeah am i correct in
that
yes and also what's interesting is that
as it spins
think of a wheel on a car as it spins it
moves forward because of the friction
that it has with the ground right
there's a contact
rolling without slipping right which is
what we learn about
in physics classes if something is
spinning it actually some of that spin
can help you carve through the air a
little bit better
than if it were not and it occurred to
me that that
if something begins to slow down and
it's no longer stabilized it could begin
to wobble
and that would increase the air
resistance as it moves through the air
whereas if it's spinning then it would
stay as a sort of flat plate
cutting through the air so that makes
sense to me and and what you make
perfect sense charles the faster it is
when it
spins when it leaves your hand the
deeper
into its path it can sustain
the stability of its of its arc how
about the hammer throw
ah even more spinning but there's no
aerodynamics in that right so there's no
no
nope that's a that's a round ball that
gets tossed
now in the olden days i bet the greeks
did not put it on as metal wire
because it know how to build wire right
or even metal balls for that matter
they probably literally threw a hammer
which is like a big long thing that they
would use to whack things right but they
actually spin around this would be a
stick onto which attached with some
heavy object at the end and you tried to
throw it and see how far you could get
it
you're allowed to spin but really the
spinning process
you have to keep your um center of
weight moving in a straight line
so it's a very complicated dance it's a
ballet really
only instead of a a beautiful pirouette
with someone wearing a tutu
right it's a brutal spin
with a gigantic individual holding a 16
pound ball on a wire
and spinning beautifully and accurately
and the release point has to be exactly
sort of
tangent to the movement so that all the
spinning
force can go to the linear trajectory of
the ball itself
of all the field sports in the olympics
the hammer throw is the one i would
least
like to be a judge for in the pit
because you have to stand in
in the in in the path of the hammer
well i'll tell you this much so i um
i i don't want to watch it anymore
because i just want to see them do it in
tutus now
okay the 2-2 hammer throw the 2-2 hammer
throw man
if the olympics knew what was good for
them they'd have that this
summer seeing as we're reinventing
charles what happens if i extend the
length of the wire on this 16 pound
cannonball
and then i start to rotate well that's
great you see the longer you have the
wire
the larger the moment of inertia
is the moment of inertia being m r
squared
the mass times the distance times the
distance again
and so to translate that rotational
motion into linear motion
the more uh the more the higher the
moment of inertia
the more angular momentum you get if
you're spinning it
at the same angular velocity just
just fancy just means that if you have a
certain number of rotations per second
the longer you have of the string the
farther the hammer will go
when you let it go because the hammer is
actually moving faster that's all right
right it's the same reason why you are
going faster on the outer horse in a
merry-go-round
than you are on an inner horse even
though everyone is on the same platter
that's right right that's why everyone
yeah if you ever you're putting a kid
to a merry-go-round take an outside as
opposed to an inside loop
the outside person will be moving much
faster and having a grander yeah like
it's twice as fast as the ones halfway
in
right right okay so now now tell me
about the javelin
my big disappointment was to learn that
people were getting so good at the
javelin
that they stands were dying
almost almost that they had to put
like an aerodynamic drag on the back of
the javelin that ain't right that no
something's wrong well
it's a little bit different from that
simply because a javelin has to come
down
point first into the ground otherwise
you run into problems if it skims along
the surface and it hits the ground goes
bounce bounce bounce bounce
right yeah we're not right right right
where did it land and there's
controversies involved with that
and that if you make sure that the
javelin lands point first in the ground
you can set yourself far enough back in
the stands
that you don't worry about being injured
so they had to move the
center of mass of the spear or the
javelin
closer toward the tip and what happened
was at first when they did that
clever speared excuse me clever javelin
designers
started messing with the back end to
make it act like you know feathers like
fletching in an
arrow or something to try to let it fly
longer and farther and things like that
and so that got banned after a short
period of time uh
but the key is they have now a days the
javelin is more like you throw it up in
the air
and it's gonna come down and it's
naturally gonna jab into the ground at
some location
okay what is that what is the optimum
angle that you have to release a javelin
to get it to go the farthest
well indoors right without any air
it's 45 degrees uh yeah
okay so this is the uh on the moon the
the airless arena
this is where we're gonna do this okay
right the answer is always 45 degrees
however let's be honest charles you're
not going to be throwing javelins
indoors very much
no you know what i've wondered in indoor
track and field championships are
there actually javelins no no no no no
the only thing you'll ever have is shot
put
indoors maybe throwing events around
that even maybe yeah
yeah okay oh well that that explains it
yes uh
the wind determines a lot
again that as we were talking about with
the discus with anything in the air
which direction whether it's an updraft
or a downdraft whether it's a headwind
or a tailwind that makes all the
difference
in any projectile i don't have the
actual angles depending on that but i
know that compensations must be made
right and it's a 45 degree angle you
learn that in physics 101
where you want it to go forward and up
with the same
initial velocity and that'll carry it
farthest to its destination
and that angle is 45 degrees every time
that's right
when we were throwing javelins to pull
through the javelin
you start with a certain angle of
approach where it's basically horizontal
to the ground
then it tilts up you keep it really
close to your ear
and then you pull through almost the
handle the binding through the center
point
and it flies and then it sails and then
it comes down but
since they were throwing they got one
german thrower whose name i cannot quite
remember
through over a hundred meters which will
have scared the living
daylights out of anybody else at the far
end of the stadium
especially the runners who are thinking
i almost got this i'm on the back
stretch and then it gets impaled
around so and there's you know you've
got all these other events happening
while javelins are being thrown so they
just had to go uh oh nope
gotta make a change so and and lastly
the shot put that's the bluntest of all
instruments here and uh
this this has like been in every single
olympics since 1896
and i understand it dates back to like
the middle ages is that right
when soldiers hurled cannonballs to
compete
is this do i have this right here yeah i
i think what we have neil is
in between battles a bunch of drunken
soldiers
picked up cannonballs and said which one
of us drunken idiots can throw this the
furthest
that sounds a lot like reality to me
okay
makes sense to me maybe they just ran
out of gun powder
and they were
this is all we got guys carry this
cannonball over and drop it on their
head
and then come back for another one while
you're at it everybody throw your musket
pellets
[Laughter]
you say that but you know what just in
the last couple of weeks from the time
we're recording this
in the last week i think ryan krause usa
broke the world record 76
feet with a 16 pound cannonball
ouch man that's that's brutally strong
and he you know there's that technique
where you glide across
the circle yes i've seen that and we've
seen all of that and there's the crouch
this is now using the discus rotation to
achieve
these distances oh so they're coiling
energy like
like the discus people do okay so it's
tactical and
and i guess it's a lot right they're not
going to say you can't do that just big
guys with a big old chalk mark under the
chin
um
what about the power of the guttural
yell
the the vocalization of shot putters
i think is the most amazing that you
hear
yeah any of those athletes it's like
this this
elephant alligator godzilla kind of
auditory utterance that simply cannot be
matched by any other human being
well they have to do that because if
they don't they'll crap themselves
is that they can't hold it in is that
what you're saying you can't hold it in
man
you got to let it out at one or other or
the other end
that's gotta come out thank you chuck
for that physiological analysis
do you have any shot-putter friends yeah
my dentist was a shot-putter
but so so charles last question before
we got to take a
quick break here the it seems to me the
shot put would be the
least susceptible to aerodynamics and so
that one you'd want to sort of throw at
a 45 degree angle i would say
probably at almost all times yeah i
don't see any reason why i don't see
a hurricane or something you know uh
that it's gonna right this
round spherical solid metal ball all
right guys
great to have you here charles lou
always great to have you on star trek
thank you thanks for being such a friend
of the show we gotta call it quits there
this has been star talk sports edition
the olympics i'm neil degrasse tyson
beating you
to keep looking up
you